Welcome to the debate.
Tonight, we turn our attention to the foundational text, The Master and the Disciple, and the rigorous insights of its 10th century author.
Tonight, the teacher answers why the learned of this community sit in their assemblies as if no living witness existed.
Every period has started with three types, a rebellious devil, a willing oppressor, and a hypocritical religious scholar.
I look at the structure of any lasting tradition and, the assertion that the leadership is somehow suppressing a living reality is a massive, destabilizing claim.
I mean, a community requires a center of gravity just to survive.
What might look like a systematic suppression of inquiry could actually be the necessary protective mechanism by which any religious group keeps itself from fracturing into 1000 pieces.
It is a heavy claim, yes.
But to truly grasp what the teacher is diagnosing in this text, we really have to look closely at the student's primary question, because it is not just some abstract theological puzzle.
It is an active, lived ache.
The disciple has already accepted a really profound premise regarding divine justice, which is the idea that divine justice actually necessitates a living witness in every single age.
Let me pause you there because we need to make sure that premise is crystal clear for everyone listening.
Why exactly does the student believe divine justice demands that?
Well, because if you believe in a perfectly just creator, you must believe that the creator does not demand obedience to a standard that is frankly impossible to reach or understand.
The chain of guidance can never be entirely cut.
If that chain were severed, it would essentially legitimize ignorance.
A person could stand before God and say, I had no living guide to show me the way.
So they'd have a valid excuse.
Exactly.
Therefore, justice requires a living witness.
But then the student looks around the society he actually lives in, and he sees this glaring contradiction.
He sees the scholars of his day.
Right.
He walks through the cities, he sits in the assemblies, and he observes that the most educated, credentialed scholars of his time have completely abandoned any inquiry into this living reality.
They just sit in their gatherings projecting absolute authority, pretending to resemble the prophets of resolution, and agreeing among themselves that they alone uphold Allah's command.
It is a striking image.
It is.
And the ache of this inquiry is profound.
I mean, if the living witness is an absolute requirement of divine justice, why do the learned members of the community act as if that witness simply does not exist?
And the teacher's response is to basically reframe the entire society, isn't it?
Yes, the one answering frames the society using a very specific structural concept.
He describes it as a closed system of three functions, temptation,
force and legitimation.
This is a mutually dependent architecture.
If you try removing any one of those functions, the whole structure collapses entirely.
I understand that the student is deeply troubled by this lack of inquiry, but we really have to look at the school's standing ground here because there is a very powerful defense for why the learned sit and maintain the status quo.
The community argues that consensus is what legitimately settles questions and provides necessary cohesion.
I mean, think about the practical reality of maintaining a civilization.
Endless inquiry is incredibly destabilizing.
It can be.
And people start chasing every charismatic claimant who steps forward.
Well, the master in the dialogue recognizes the appeal of that stability, certainly.
But he argues that what you are calling cohesion is actually the cessation of spiritual vitality.
But look at how the community achieves that cohesion.
They use the slogan, no profit after our profit.
And I would argue that this slogan requires absolutely no defense, precisely because its universal repetition is
exactly what protects the community.
Settledness, from this perspective, is a profound virtue.
A virtue.
Yes, it is not some dark conspiracy to suppress the truth.
It is the fortification of a shared reality.
By universally agreeing that the era of new prophecy is definitively closed, the community can finally focus on living out the revelation it has already received.
That is the argument of the learned.
Yes, they lean heavily on that.
And it works.
The repetition of the slogan builds an impenetrable wall against false claimants.
It provides everyday believers with immense psychological and spiritual security.
They don't have to wake up every morning wondering if the foundational rules of their universe have changed.
Consensus provides a floor to stand on.
It provides a floor, but it also locks the doors and shuts the windows.
The teacher identifies that settledness is not a virtue at all.
It is the primary engine of decay.
How so?
Because once a community decides a matter is completely settled, inquiry becomes redundant.
But the psychology of the community does not stop at redundancy.
That redundancy very quickly turns into suspicion of anyone who still dares to ask questions.
give it a little more time, and that suspicion hardens into strict prohibition.
So you are saying the environment shifts from we don't need to ask to you are not allowed to ask?
Precisely.
The scholars who once upon a time might have asked the difficult questions, well, they stop asking.
The younger scholars who never thought to ask are confirmed in their non-asking.
The surface of the community closes entirely, sealing out any possibility of living guidance.
I don't buy that yet.
Three actors sounds neat, but how is this different from any generic elites conspire story?
I mean, throughout history, people who are dissatisfied with the establishment always claim that the rulers and the clerics are working together in the shadows to suppress the real truth.
It is a common trope, sure.
It is a very common rhetorical tool used to delegitimize authority.
Whenever someone is unhappy with the status quo, why should we view this text any differently?
It is fundamentally different because the teacher is not describing a generic, mundane accumulation of political power.
He is detailing a highly specific mechanism of epistemological control.
Every period has started with three types.
a rebellious devil, a willing oppressor, and a hypocritical religious scholar.
Walk me through how those three specific functions operate together then.
Why does it have to be those three?
Because none of the three could do the work alone.
The rebellious devil produces the temptation, making falsehood attractive to the heart.
The willing oppressor produces the force, making opposition physically or socially costly.
And the hypocritical scholar produces the legitimation, making acquiescence look like religious virtue.
It really is a closed system.
Exactly.
Think about the mechanics of it.
The temptation without the force does not last, because people will eventually see through it if they're not coerced.
The force without the legitimation does not hold, because a population will eventually overthrow A tyrant who relies only on pure brutality.
and the legitimation without the temptation has nothing to dignify.
So the scholar's role is essentially to provide the theological cover for the oppressor's violence.
Yes.
If the oppressor threatens the masses, the scholar stands up and tells the masses that obeying the oppressor is the will of God.
Their joint product specifically severs the outward traces of prophecy from its living continuation.
The teacher uses a really vital concept here, the artifact versus the source.
How does the text define the artifact?
Books, rituals, and the names of prophets remain merely as a commodity.
They are preserved perfectly.
But the living function, the source, that can actually answer a new question, the living witness has been entirely severed.
Leaving the community with just the outer shell.
Right, the community is left holding this physical artifact, the empty vessel of religion, genuinely believing they possess the living reality.
The assertion that these scholars are actively structurally involved in this severance is a massive charge.
It implies that the learned are not merely mistaken in their theology, but are the crucial third load-bearing pillar in an ongoing structure of oppression.
It is a heavy charge, yes, but it is a charge supported directly by the foundational texts themselves.
The Quran names this triangular pressure explicitly.
Where exactly?
In the chapter on the confederates, we see a chilling scene of the followers themselves on the day of accounting.
They say, Our Lord, we obeyed our chiefs and our great ones, and they misled us from the way.
The chiefs and the great ones.
Exactly.
That names two of the three actors with absolute precision.
The chiefs are the oppressors who apply the force.
The great ones are the credentialed scholars whose religious authority dignified the chiefs.
Furthermore, the chapter on the table spread sharpens this indictment even more.
By addressing the scholars directly.
By condemning the silence of the scholars who did not forbid one another from the wrongdoing they committed.
It is the silence of the learned that brings the curse down upon the community.
Does this structural critique appear in the sayings of the prophet as well, or is it isolated to those
those Quranic chapters.
Oh, it is deeply embedded in the prophetic tradition.
The Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, warned explicitly of the learned of corruption.
The learned of corruption.
Yes.
In a very well attested hadith recorded by Bay Haqi in the Hadith collection, the warning is terrifyingly clear.
It says a time will come when nothing remains of Islam except its name and nothing of the Quran except its script.
The mosques will be full of magnificent buildings, but entirely empty of guidance, and the learned will be the worst people under the sky.
Because they maintain the artifact while suppressing the source.
Exactly.
This is the absolute tight portrait of the third actor.
The buildings remain, the artifacts are beautifully preserved, the rituals are performed flawlessly, but the living guidance is severed.
The scholar sits in the assembly, holding the artifact, and uses it to block the door to the living witness.
That sounds like wordplay.
Calling the slogan an engine just renames repetition.
Does this actually map to the historical reality of earlier traditions?
I mean, it is very easy to claim theoretically that repeating no profit after our profit shuts down inquiry, but the historical survival of communities often relies on exactly this kind of boundary drawing.
Is not theoretical wordplay, actually.
It maps perfectly to historical reality.
The teacher performs a historical roll call for the student to prove that this is a recurring, predictable social fact.
He points first to the Zoroastrians.
Okay, what is their boundary?
They cling fiercely to their fire temples, declaring with absolute certainty that Allah will never send a messenger after Zoroaster.
They drew their boundary around the artifact.
Right, and then he points to the community of the Torah.
They tend to their calf, they submit entirely to their judges, and they declare with the exact same certainty that Allah will never send a messenger after Moses.
Then he points to the community of the Gospels.
They venerate
with their priests.
They worship their prophet as God, and they declare that Allah will never send a messenger after Jesus.
So the specific artifact changes depending on the era.
Precisely.
In every single instance, the artifact differs, whether it is the fire temple, the calf, or the priesthood, but the structure is perfectly identical.
And now the teacher tells the student, look around you.
This community has followed the exact step-by-step ways of those who preceded them.
By holding onto their own artifacts.
They have inherited the book from those unworthy of it, they have followed the seductions of their leaders, and they are repeating the exact same slogan of finality.
The outward traces remain, but the living reality is gone.
The current community thinks its settledness proves it is exceptional, but the historical pattern demonstrates it is simply the latest case of the exact same phenomenon.
I come at it from a different way.
If this structure is so absolute,
doesn't it render the entire community, every everyday follower, wicked and fully complicit?
If the system relies on the absolute closure of inquiry and the masses participate in the rituals while blindly repeating the slogan, your framework seems to indict the everyday believer just as harshly as the oppressor or the hypocritical scholar.
That is a crucial question.
But the text does not condemn the masses in the same way.
The teacher actually provides a quiet, profound pastoral observation here.
The followers are not deeply convinced.
They are terrified.
Terrified of what?
They are terrified by the weight of scholarly consensus, and they are terrified by the physical tyranny of the rulers.
So compliance is basically a survival mechanism.
Yes.
The diagnosis is infinitely harsher on the three actors at the top of the system than on the followers downstream.
The average member of the community follows the great majority not out of some deep, rigorous theological conviction that the living witness is gone, but because dissent from consensus is socially and spiritually expensive.
And, well, the rulers make it physically dangerous.
They are trapped between the two pillars.
In the collected sayings, he states that the ruin of the religion comes about by two figures, a corrupt scholar and an ignorant worshiper.
How does the worshiper cause ruin?
The worshipper deceives the everyday people with his surface-level piety and adherence to the artifacts, while the scholar deceives them with his corruption and false legitimation.
The everyday follower is squeezed between the force of the state and the legitimation provided by the scholars.
They abandon inquiry because asking questions is simply too dangerous.
I can see that the pressure of the state and the crushing weight of scholarly authority can produce compliance based on fear rather than genuine conviction.
However, the school's core defense still rests heavily on the argument from consensus.
Even if fear plays a part in human society, the consensus of the community across time remains the strongest metric we have for determining truth in the absence of absolute certainty.
The agreement of the majority must carry epistemological weight, or else we have no measure for truth at all.
The teacher anticipates that exact defense, and he systematically dismantles it by turning the logic of consensus backward against the community itself.
He presents the one who asks with a chronological trap.
A chronological trap?
How does that work?
He tells the student, look, let us use your own metric.
If we must acknowledge the truth of this community strictly on the basis of its mutual consensus, then the earlier communities are mathematically and historically even more deserving of acknowledgement.
Just because they have been around longer.
No, because of the direction of mutual confirmation.
Think about it.
By the metric of mutual consensus,
All later groups confirm the earlier prophets, but no earlier group confirms the latest.
This latest community confirms the validity of Moses and confirms the validity of Jesus.
But the earlier communities do not confirm this community's prophet.
Therefore, the earlier communities possess the broader, more universal consensus.
The latest community stands entirely alone in its specific claims.
Let me process that.
If we define truth by the sheer volume of cross-community agreement.
If consensus is your ultimate infallible measure of truth, you must concede to the earlier traditions because they hold the much larger share of mutual agreement across time.
the latest community uses consensus to validate its finality without realizing that by relying on consensus, they are validating the superiority of the groups that reject them.
When you frame it as a chronological measure of mutual confirmation, that defense genuinely collapses.
I mean, the community cannot use consensus to prove its own finality without inadvertently proving the superiority of the traditions that preceded it.
The metric completely turns against the user.
And once the defensive consensus falls apart, the master in the dialogue introduces the ultimate reality collapse via divine sovereignty.
Well, the community often tries to argue that the matter is simply settled by divine decree, that God has simply chosen to end the chain of living witnesses, and that is why inquiry is closed.
But the teacher argues that such a view attempts to place limits on the Creator.
Allah is engaged in a new work every
The Creator possesses the absolute, unbound right to create, to command, to abrogate, and to confirm exactly as He wills.
To say the chain of guidance is permanently closed and that the artifact is all we will ever have is an attempt by the scholars to bind divine sovereignty.
To essentially tie God's hands to their own theology?
Exactly.
Here, the text presents us with two shut doors.
the door of consensus, and the door of finalized divine decree.
The door of consensus defeated itself through the chronological trap we just discussed.
The appeal to a finalized divine decree is defeated by the reality of God's continuous sovereign engagement with His creation.
Those 2 doors are firmly shut.
Leaving only one option.
It leaves only one logical path forward.
It leaves only the door to the living witness.
Looking at the sheer magnitude of this framework, it is very clear why the historian Corbin and the historian Deftary recognized this text as a profound intellectual shift in how religious history is understood.
I mean, this was the moment where teachers systematized the recurring failure of communities.
They didn't just view corruption as a contingent misfortune, a bad ruler here, a lazy scholar there.
They framed it as a structural feature of human history.
It elevates the observation of corruption from a simple complaint into a comprehensive sociological and cosmological doctrine.
It is a doctrine that repeats in every era.
Every period has started with three types.
A rebellious devil, a willing oppressor, and a hypocritical religious scholar.
Which slogan repeated in your own circles has made inquiry feel disloyal, and what would it cost this week to ask the question you have been avoiding?